batman is arguably the most iconic comic
book hero of all time but what's his
connection with the senator from vermont
who are the real life batman and who
really came up with the character in the
first place keep watching to find out
more about everyone's favorite caped
crusader most people are aware of the
impact that bob kane had on the creation
of the world's greatest detective but he
wasn't the only person who can put his
name to batman indeed when bill finger
earned a credit as the character's
co-creator in 2015 it marked the end of
a long struggle for recognition for this
little known comic book writer in recent
years it has become widely accepted that
finger was responsible for many of the
innovations that have previously been
credited to kane this included the idea
to turn kane's red-shirted early concept
for batman into the design that
ultimately became the dark knight's
first costume not only that but finger
also conceived co-created or
co-developed both alfred and
commissioner gordon as well as catwoman
the joker and even robin the latter two
were also heavily influenced by jerry
robinson who designed both characters
and who according to him actually came
up with the joker in the first place
robinson also claims that he gave the
boy wonder his superhero name of course
none of this is to say that bob kane
didn't have a hand in crafting batman's
world but his contributions are as
overstated as finger and robinsons are
overlooked
in addition to the many characters that
influence bill finger and bob kane when
creating batman the dark knight himself
has a few in-universe heroes who
inspired his superhero career the most
well-known of course is zorro the
legendary swordsman is fictional in
bruce wayne's world but his black caped
costume imprinted itself onto bruce's
mind when he saw the mark of zorro on
the night his parents were killed
another major figure who led bruce to
the life of a vigilante was the original
green lantern alan scott this iteration
of the green lantern not only defended
gotham in the mid-20th century but also
met a young thomas wayne bruce also has
a childhood connection to allen having
once witnessed the green lantern evade
several blasts from the original icicles
called gun batman the animated series
introduces another costumed role model
for bruce wayne the grey ghost a
fictional tv hero played by simon trent
whose voice actor happens to be none
other than adam west
as a kid
i used to watch you with my father
the great ghost was my hero
so it wasn't all for nothing
both the grey ghost and his alter ego
are eventually introduced in the main
comics continuity though not
simultaneously the grey ghost debuts in
comics with a different man under the
mask named clancy johnson while simon
trent makes his first incontinuity
appearance in gotham academy issue 4
drawing dc's new 52 timeline
a surprising debate has raged within the
batman fandom in recent years does
batman kill some might point to batman v
superman dawn of justice in which he
clearly does kill more than a few people
the same holds true in the two tim
burton directed batman movies in
christopher nolan's dark knight trilogy
batman is more than happy to let his
enemies die even if he refuses to kill
them himself hardcore batman fans
however will point out that movies
aren't exactly the source material and
in the comics the issue is far more
complicated batman certainly has no
problem dispatching his foes during his
earliest appearances but he moves away
from the practice not long after robin
enters the picture those early killings
are removed from the main batman's
history when the golden age batman is
retconned into having existed on earth
too since then batman has been largely
against killing once even calling murder
theft of the highest order that said
he's been known to break this rule
having been responsible for a few deaths
in certain runs and he even tries to
kill raz al-ghul in batman annual issue
8. he also may have unintentionally
killed a few dolphins armed with plastic
explosives in detective comics issue 405
although for some reason this incident
doesn't seem to come up much during fans
arguments over the subject
ask anyone what colors batman's costumes
tend to be and they'll probably list off
black blue grey and yellow what they
might not know however is that batman's
very first costume also included a color
more commonly associated with his
greatest enemy that's right in addition
to being much smaller than they'd later
become batman's gloves were once purple
batman's small purple gloves are a
one-issue wonder appearing in his debut
story in detective comics issue 27 the
dark knight would then leave his hands
bare in issue 28 and on the cover of
issue 29 before very overtly deciding to
wear blue gloves on the pages of that
same issue since then his handware has
been mostly black gray and blue but the
purple gloves have returned on a few
notable occasions
these include scott snyder and greg
coppolo's zero year storyline from 2013
in which they form a part of a more
makeshift costume for batman they also
showed up on the golden age version of
batman and detective comics issue 1027
and the two recent generations one shots
you might think the famous giant penny
in batman's cave is a memento snagged
from two-face given how coins are
essential to his decision-making process
you live
you die
now we're talking
in some cases you'd be right in the
post-crisis continuity the massive
copper coin is revealed to be two faces
it also belonged to him in batman the
animated series originally however the
man behind the mammoth penny is he aptly
named joe coyne who debuts in world's
finest comics issue 30. years of
frustration from constantly trying to
amass wealth and only ending up with
pennies leads coin to coin himself the
penny plunderer he swears revenge on the
police who have incarcerated him by
dedicating himself to crime with pennies
as a signature motif batman and robin
confront the plunderer at the museum
while coin and his gang are trying to
steal an oversized one-cent stamp in the
process they managed to subdue some of
the thieves with a giant penny that
happens to be at the same exhibition not
long thereafter the penny ends up in
batman's cave since then pretty much
every origin story for the penny has
either involved a penny plunderer
two-face or even both characters
interestingly the same series that
introduces the penny world's finest
comics later contradicts this earlier
origin for the penny by saying batman
had obtained it while dueling the joker
maybe giant pennies just aren't that
hard to come by in gotham city
batman is no stranger to strange
adventures and by the end of the 1940s
the character had encountered bizarre
super villains time travel and even
martians yet when the 1950s and early
60s rolled around batman began feeling a
little more super during these stories
batman's comic book adventures became
far more similar to superman's as alien
threats sci-fi gadgets and monsters crop
up more often similarly batman's allies
who already included robin and
occasionally batwoman expand into a
full-on bat family echoing how a super
family formed around superman during the
same time period
these growing similarities to superman
were far from accidental dc comics
management at the time pushed batman
editor jack schiff into having the caped
crusaders comics emulate the man of
steels whose comics outsold batman's by
quite imagine sadly that sales gap
didn't narrow when batman tried doing
things superman's way prompting the dark
knight's adventures to revert to a more
successful back to basics approach in
1964.
if you've ever looked at batman's
zurinar costume and decided that nobody
on earth would ever willingly wear
something like that well you wouldn't be
that far off from the truth originally
the suit belongs to an alien named
tilano who becomes a batman of the
planet to zurina after viewing the
original batman's exploits with
long-range equipment talano then enlists
his role model's help in fending off an
invasion from another alien world and
batman is surprised to discover that
simply being on talano's planet grants
him super strength invulnerability and
flight sound familiar small wonder as
the story from batman issue 113 is
titled batman superman of planet x
during writer grant morrison's run on
batman the batman of zoroana is
retconned into being bruce wayne himself
specifically an alternate persona
created to counter mind control
consequently the events of batman issue
113 are explained as a hallucination
induced by simon hurt and perhaps even a
subconscious desire on batman's part to
have powers like superman this would
also explain why the zoronar costume is
so colourful although batman overtly
seems to attribute that to robin in
batman issue 680 and it's hard not to
note the visual similarities between the
two as to where the name zoronar comes
from a misremembered zorro in arkham
which is the end of a sentence thomas
wayne utters after he martha and bruce
have finished watching the mark of zorro
one strange quirk of bruce wayne's life
is that crucially important events often
seem to happen to him while he's
attending masquerade balls one example
is a costume party held in his youth at
which his father wears a bat-themed
disguise and is even referred to as a
batman when he wins a prize for best
costume clearly the getup leaves an
impact on bruce as he himself admits in
the same issue soon after batman even
puts on the outfit himself to scare
mobster lou moxen simon hurt also wears
a costume as part of his ploy to
convince batman that he is thomas and
somehow survive joe chill's attack the
other masquerade ball that leaves a mark
on bruce is the one at which barbara
gordon debuts as batgirl in detective
comics issue 359 one of the biggest
scenes in the film batman returns even
takes place at a masquerade ball in
which bruce wayne and selena kyle learn
each other's costumed identities and the
penguin abducts his former associate max
shrek then in the dark knight rises a
slightly less extravagant masquerade
event plays host to another meeting
between bruce wayne and selena
you're all gonna wonder how you ever
thought you could live so large and
leave so little for the rest of us
most of batman's partners in crime
fighting are pretty conventional as far
as sidekicks go naturally there are the
many robins who have worked for him over
the years some of whom have graduated to
new identities such as nightwing there
have also been multiple batgirls along
with unique junior heroes such as
bluebird there are some pretty strange
outliers however one such example is
jaro a tiny leftover piece of starro the
conqueror that batman takes in as his
own and places in a jar in the hall of
justice the diminutive starfish views
batman as a father and dreams of
becoming his next crime-fighting partner
even donning a small robin costume at
one point and holding his own against
the legion of doom he also happens to be
the strongest sidekick the dc universe
has ever known batman sidekicks get even
odder once you venture outside of
continuity the bizarro world graphic
novel for instance introduces monkey the
monkey wonder a circus monkey batman
adopts and tries to induct into the
crime-fighting life to less than stellar
results
dc's heroes have often been compared to
mythological characters with batman
being frequently equated to hades or
pluto so it's perhaps natural that he
has particularly unique interactions
with darkseid the new god of the fiery
planet apocalypse in superman batman
issue 12 for instance batman earns a
god's respect by threatening to create
hundreds of new fire bits across the
planet unless darkseid releases its hold
on supergirl the two face off again
during final crisis when batman fires a
bullet at him made of radeon dark side
retaliates by sending batman back in
time with his omega beams simultaneously
turning the dark knight into a kind of
bomb against time itself there have been
times where batman has also served
darkseid albeit not always lowly
when the justice league accidentally
hands earth to dark side on a platter by
destroying the philosopher's stone in
the jla story rock of ages batman gains
a new god's trust by posing as the
infamous apocalyptian torturer dasar
this storyline likely influenced
batman's role in justice league dark
apocalypse war which is set in a future
where dark sides also conquered earth
and the dark knight serves him willingly
having been brainwashed
rather than disguising himself as one of
darkseid's traditional servants however
batman performs his duties as himself
albeit connected to metron's mobius
chair a nod to another comic book saga
the dark side war
bruce wayne officially begins his
crusade as batman as an early adult
meaning he never spent any time as a
teenage superhero yet in the elseworld
story titan's scissor paper stone a
teenager named jamadagni renuka attaches
a device to her ex-boyfriend alex von
wick's neck downloading batman's
personality into his mind while he's
never outright confirmed to be the
original dark knight the mentally
transformed alex demeanor gruff voice
and deductive skills make it pretty
clear he's meant to be the batman
himself in this story he's given a
different code name captain thug while
jama dagny and her friends are
christened names like witchy poo and
prosthetic lass which are subtle
references to teen titans raven and
cyborg that said in the main dcu cannon
multiple teen titans have taken on the
batman mantle during battle for the cowl
ex-titans jason todd and tim drake
briefly assumed the batman identity dick
grayson the titans original leader has
also been batman in both the 1990s
prodigal storyline and after darkseid
sends bruce wayne back in time
many readers of dc comics during the
1990s may remember elseworlds a dc
comics sub-imprint meant to reinterpret
dc's characters in various ways
throughout that decade and into the
early 2000s elseworld stories were a
staple of the dc line with several of
the imprint stories being incorporated
into the dc equivalent of the multiverse
the funny thing is that else worlds was
essentially created by accident
according to writer editor
extraordinaire brian augustine who wrote
the very first issue without realizing
it at the time batman gotham by gaslight
as he explained in the deluxe edition of
the graphic novel gotham by gaslight
first came about when fellow comics
giant mark wade suggested an annual of
the secret origins title that told
alternative histories of dc favorites
essentially the germ of what else worlds
would become gotham by gaslight however
became a standalone story instead and
years of elseworld specials one shots
and graphic novels followed in the same
vein interestingly the first comic to
actually be given the title elseworlds
was not gotham by gaslight but another
batman story namely batman holy terror
written by secret origins contributor
alan brennert
several big name actors have come close
to assuming the role of the caped
crusader at one point or another from
p.s brosnan to bill murray interestingly
many of the performers who almost became
batman still ended up appearing in
superhero movies primarily as villains
josh brolin was considered for the role
of the dark knight in batman v superman
dawn of justice but instead wound up
taking his mcu role as thanos to great
heights he also became a major marvel
comics hero cable and deadpool 2. jake
gyllenhaal also auditioned for the role
of batman and christopher nolan's films
and eventually joined the mcu as
mysterio in spider-man far from home
some actors who almost played batman
even landed a villain role in the very
same film killian murphy auditioned for
the role of batman and batman begins and
was later cast a scarecrow instead he's
here
who
the batman
meanwhile heath ledger who played the
joker in the dark knight declined to
play batman and begins after being
offered the part personally by nolan
amazingly leger's reason for doing so
was that he claimed he would never take
a part in a superhero film
in addition to inspiring cosplayers
around the world to don his cal gotham's
creature of the night has imitators who
have gone as far as to adapt his
superhero lifestyle too canada has
brampton batman aka steven lawrence who
spends his evenings helping those in
need and even stopping the occasional
crime
like this
i can if you'd
there's also alexander brovidani alias
toronto batman though largely retired he
still makes an occasional public
appearance japan meanwhile has chi
batman the batman like hero of the city
chiba he once told the bbc his goal is
to bring the smiles back to everyone he
meets ever since the 2011 great east
japan earthquake dark knights have also
been spotted around the us as well the
most endearing perhaps being bat kid
whose famous one day turn as a caped
crusader is the subject of the
documentary bat kid begins sadly not
every batman has shared bruce wayne's
long career the batman of the us state
of maryland lenny b robinson died during
a traffic accident in 2015. nevertheless
he left behind an admirable legacy of
brightening children's days whenever
he'd set foot in hospitals dressed as
gotham city's most famous defender
not every government official in gotham
city likes batman but he's got himself
at least one major real-life politician
on his side u.s senator patrick leahy of
vermont leahy has been in nearly every
batman movie from batman forever through
the dark knight trilogy and up to batman
v superman only skipping batman begins
along the way he's even lent a voice to
batman the animated series in which he
played the governor leahy sat out the
batman however as much as he'd have
liked to take part he explained that his
workload as senator kept him from making
his customary trips to gotham for matt
reeves movie in addition to joining
batman on the silver screen leahy has
added his own dab of ink to batman's
comic book adventures both detective
comics 80 years of batman and batman
death of innocence the horror of
landmines bear text pieces written by
the senator as leahy told the washington
post the latter comic which the vermont
politician gave to the entire senate may
have actually been instrumental in
getting his historic anti-landmine
legislation passed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite heroes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you